Number 10: Many recent presidents have been lefties.
They include President Obama, Bill Clinton, George H. W. Bush and Gerald Ford.
Number 9: It's decided early on.
Studies have shown that whatever hand one uses most as a 10-week-old fetus...
...is the one they'll favor for the rest of their lives.
Number 8: lefties are more likely to experience fear.
Number 7: older women are more likely to have a lefty baby.
Number 6: It's a family thing.
Among the more famous relations to have a slew of them is Britain's royal family.
Number 5: Lefties are faster thinkers.
Information travels more quickly between their hemispheres,...
...making them more efficient in a multitude of tasks, including multitasking.
Number 4: The left-handed club has many famous members.
They include Bill Gates, Oprah Winfrey, Lady Gaga, Angelina Jolie, and Nicole Kidman.
Number 3: They tend to run hot.
As in, on the angry side.
Number 2: speech sounds different to lefties.
Number 1: Southpaws tend to be more inhibited.
A university study revealed that left-handed participants...
...were more likely to express anxiety, shyness or embarrassment...
...when faced with an unfamiliar situation.